thank you all for joining me today my
name is Nida um and today we're going to
talk about how to utilize or unlock the
full potential of Jupiter notebooks uh
and use them in production so let's
start talking about Jupiter notebooks
Jupiter notebooks have revolutionized
how we build machine learning projects
becoming the de facto standard tool for
data scientists to give you a sense of
its impact Jupiter has was awarded the
2017 ACM soft sofware award system a
Prestige honor re shures with Java unex
and the
web however using it to build ml
projects and application for production
has introduced CH challenges never
encountered before the new and undefined
format structure and workflow revealed
blind spots that made its usage in
production environment an uphill battle
and in our session today I will share
seven best practices that will help you
reduce the time between the initial
prototyping using notebooks to deploying
them to production and we're going to
use it for with various amops tools and
techniques and a few words about me I'm
Nida and thank you all for joining me
today my backgrounds uh combines
structure analysis computer vision
engineering and amops research I lead uh
the mlops and Outreach team at dsab
which in a one line is the data for
machine learning so a centralized place
to host and manage your project
including your code your data your
models experiments and so on and my team
is
researching uh and implementing mlop
Solutions and workflows for
collaborating on ML uh project and this
session aims to bring you the essence of
what we've learned over the years and
about how to use Jupiter notebooks in a
production environment and so far the
the hypothesis that had the highest
statistical significant is that the best
way to get data scientist attention is
by using three phrases notebook
production and melops and today today
we're going to have them
all um so let's start with the Dark Side
of notebooks and from there move towards
the light hopefully it's not going to be
a train that is heading directly to our
Direction so the Dark Side of notebooks
with notebooks we can run out of order
code and edit the cells after they have
already been ran once this is a huge
disadvantage for reproducibility and
makes us put a lot of effort into
tracking the kernel State when executing
an experiment behind the scenes Jupiter
notebooks are basically a very large
Json files that can't easily be diffed
by git which makes it very hard to
review and last but not least the code
hosted in our Jupiter notebooks is not
colable outside the notebook which makes
it very hard for testing and reusing so
why do we even use Jupiter notebooks
let's just throw them out of the window
and go back to the good old IDE well
notebooks are a great tool after all
that gives us superhuman abilities they
give us an interactive way to work with
our code they have built-in
visualizations and we can see the
results next to the code that's Rand
them and this is also a a benefit for
communicating our work to our c
colleagues or to are not so technical
stockholders that just want to see
graphs and all of this means that
jupyter notebooks are a very good tool
for quick prototyping and now that we
agree that Jupiter notebooks are a good
tool that we can make benefit Farm let's
see how we can make it more efficient
and use it more efficiently and overcome
their
drawbacks so to do so we encountered uh
we conducted a user research at dagup
interviewing hundreds of data scientists
amalo engineers VPS CTO and found that
when using Jupiter notebooks and
following seven simple principles you
can drama dramatically improve your
productivity scalability and
reproducibility which is a big factor in
AML projects and what we'd like to do is
first host our code in modules outside
of our jupyter notebook version
everything have peer review when using
Jupiter notebooks track experiments use
test oriented notebooks track
environment settings and use scripts for
training and deployment and this list
might sound a bit uh ambiguous so let's
see how it works in practice and take a
common scenario as our use case and in
this in in our use case our team lead
just got out the phone with the CEO and
there's a new project in the funnel save
the planet surprisingly the CEO wants it
in production by end of week because
it's a freaking game Cher yeah this is
fair new so you roll up your sleeves you
put on your headset you find the perfect
Jam to for this task you open your
desktop and you're going to get some
coffee no I'm kidding you're going to
download the data set to your local
machine open a new notebook and start
exploring your
data okay but hold your horses Cowboy
this is not your first rodeo you've
already created a one-of A- kind never
heard of data analysis plots but where
are they so we start firing up all
notebooks scrolling through dozens of
cells and outputs looking into hundreds
of cod lines just to find that one
function that you're looking for but
although witnessing the outstanding work
that we did a few months back it's
highly time consuming and we wanted an
easy way to search for the pieces of
code that we need and this among other
things or other reasons is a very good
reason to move our code into modules and
what do I mean by that after getting our
initial piece of code to do what it was
designed to do we refactor it into a
python function that doesn't rely on any
Global variable and takes everything as
an argument so it's going to look
something like this um where we have a
plug of global warming distribution and
now we're going to take this function
and convert it into a module that
doesn't rely on any uh or any Global
variable and we're going to store this
function in a python script outside of
the notebook and then we're going to
import it back to our notebook and use
it and when we're going to build our
project this way and I think this is the
most
significant uh piece of advice that I
can give you because this is going to to
dramatically improve your uh your
workflow and Your Efficient we're going
to unlock uh
three
um we're going to unlock a world of
opportunities so first and foremost
we're going to have we can be able to
use Co static code analysis tools to
flag programming errors and bugs we're
going to be able to run uniest uh on the
functions to make sure that we don't
fail in production and we're going to
stay dry meaning we're not going to
repeat ourselves we can now easily use
pieces of code in this notebook or in
any other notebooks that we're going to
open in this project on or other
projects and this is a good time to take
a zip of
water so now that we can move faster
without breaking anything sorry Mark we
can now start exploring our data but
what should we do when we're reaching a
good results or better yet a dead end so
should we just copy cells to the bottom
of the notebook just to make sure that
we don't lose them or should we Stone AG
version our notebooks by copying and
pasting it and giving it a unique name
version one version two the the nicest
plot Etc only if there was a magical
tool that enables Version Control with
the power of going back in time oh right
we have git so versioning our notebook
with Git gives us all once again
superhuman abilities so we can work in
an isolated environment recover our work
use cicd for automations and the list
just goes on and on but aren't we
neglecting something here remember we're
working on a data science project and in
our project we not only you don't only
need to version our code we also need to
version our data our models and our
pipelines which in most cases the
version of the non code components is
going to become the focal point of our
experiment and therefore we want to be
able to version them and also retrieve
them easily so for that many tools
emerge in recent years for data and pipe
and versioning that are oriented towards
different task and use cases or type of
data set so I would recommend to
research for the tool that best fits
your needs uh we have DBC Pock GFS Delta
Lake L fs and the list just goes on and
on but once we're going to use those
tools that are oriented towards our data
towards our models towards our pipeline
to version them we'll be able to uh make
to avoid ad hoc versioning and make sure
that all of our project is encapsulated
we'll also be able to share uh versions
of our code and modules within the team
easily without making copies or uh
sending links to our bucket or our
Google drive or whatever and most
importantly we'll be able to reproduce
our results with a click of a
button so we broke down explor and
tested our data to create the monola of
reports really it's a thing of beauty so
we feel comfortable to start processing
it but what if we missed something what
if there's a hidden bias in our work or
our hypothesis isn't supported by the
data our work should be passed under the
magnifying glass of our colleagues and
this is an important step step that in
most cases is
overlooked we'd like to use reviewing
tools that enable us uh sell and output
diffing and communicating with context
and at xub we're using NB dime under the
hood to compare notebooks and we
developed our own mechanism for cell
commenting so in this case you can click
on a cell add a comment and then in the
code review or the pull request the uh
the person who opened it will be able to
get your uh review very easily without
taking screenshots or moving to slack or
any other third party uh platform for
communicating um we know I know that Gab
is using review and NB and there's tons
of different tools and plugins for
different
notebooks um but by using that we'll be
able to review our work we'll make it uh
we'll be able to reduce the bias in our
work and once again we'll be able to
find bugs easily um and this is a very
important step before moving to
production um so we have another set of
eyes looking on our
code another zip of
water cool so we're 3 days into the
project and we haven't run a single cell
that contains fit we want to train a
model and we want to do it now but
before before we do that keep in mind
that we're conducting a research here
this is not a software development
project experimenting without logging
the parameters the results is basically
meaningless because you can't really
compare Apple to Apples once we're going
to reach to a good result so we need to
keep track of everything that we're
doing and for that uh like with large
file versioning many tools emerge in
recent years for experiment tracking and
in this case I I think that it doesn't
really matter with which Hammer you
choose to heit The Nail as long as you
punch it through and by using this
Hammer we'll be we'll be able to build
our knowledge base as we go we'll be
able to reproduce our results and
experiments to some extent because we're
only logging the the hyper parameters
and the results so those this is the
information that we'll be able to
retrieve back and also once again we'll
be able to avoid manual recording using
spreadsheets or whatnot and we're we're
going to build proper workflows or this
is going to be a guard rail for our team
to use um all together in the same
tool and now the deadline is closing in
and you're find yourself going back and
forth between processing and modeling
trying to process the data differently
maybe retag it reannotate it and then
run the training again and you start to
feeling the heat from your boss to the
point where she decides to add two more
te team members to the task but now what
how can we collaborate together we're
going to all work on a giant notebook
okay so Dean you're going to take sales
1 to 29 guy is going to take sales 30 to
50 and I'm going to work on sales 60 and
above but wait please don't run sell 55
because it takes for hours to
load this doesn't make sense right so we
don't want to work this way because in
most like in in most uh it most likely
going to result in stepping on each
other's toes we'd like to use a
designated notebook perir task from the
get go so for every task let's say for
processing for uh Eda for modeling Etc
each test is going to get its own
designated notebook and we're going to
able to produce at the end a report per
step so if I'm going to if a peer would
like to review your work they will be
able to just go go to the notebook and
see the results of the Eda
pre-processing modeling
Etc and by using a designated notebook
pair task we'll be able to scale up or
down the number of women or men power on
the task it's going to make our notebook
easier to review and maintain because
they're going to be shorter and task
oriented and our project is going to
have a clear structure because each step
is going to get a designated
notebook us aome so we're 6 hour before
the deadline and we have one last
training that we need to run but the
person in charge of modeling just called
in sick my God I just wish this week is
going to be over with so you connect to
your favorite cloud provider which there
is no such thing you fire a monster
machine pull the latest version of The
Notebook and hit run all sales okay pray
with me pray with me we're going to hit
it we're going to hit it and train
what error retrieving driver version ker
reported driver version not implementing
not implemented what now so we're
getting errors because our version of
tensor flow doesn't support this
driver my God so notebooks need to be
reproducible in the sense was that
anyone on the team should be able to
take your notebook and rerun it in the
same using the same input and get the
same output and for that
we should we should determine and
recreate the environment required for
the notebook to be executed and in other
words requirements.txt but I highly
recommend I highly recommend not
stopping there and containerizing your
environment to ensure that it's isolated
it doesn't require any OS level
dependencies and by using that we'll be
able to uh we will unlock
reproducibility uh and enable to share
our work with anyone anyone will be able
to pick up our work from where we left
it so it can be our team a different
team member ourselves in six months
trying to debug our model or hand offing
uh the project to our peers or to the
amop steam that is going to try to
deploy the model to
production water is important so
please uh okay yeah this is a good
connection so please uh don't deploy
your model to production this way so by
using uh or deploying your models to
production uh or deploying the The
Notebook itself to okay yeah I kind of
lost it but I'm going to cycle back CU
this was a good meme that hit me off so
basically the bridge here is we're going
to want to deploy our notebook to
production and I highly recommend not
doing that not deploy do not deploy your
model to production there are so many
drawback when using notebooks in
production that the list just too big to
handle so there are no uh proper or very
wellestablished cicd tools that are Wily
using the uh industry um also we're
going to H need to make a lot of
cleaning up and packaging of our
notebooks before we're going to use them
in production because they're probably
going to be too heavy with different
plots and y y yada and also notebooks
are not that good of a team player
they're not um you can't really use them
very easily with other tools especially
with cicd tools so what I recommend is
when we're going to move our code into
modules and we're going to have our
project ready to deployment then create
a main uh script and use this script for
inference and for deployment and this
leads us to one last principle is to use
scripts in production which is the
industry standard and much more easier
to maintain debug and reduce the
downtime um scripts are better when
we're working at scale and we want to
scale up or down uh and there they can
handle uh heavy loads and this is also
uh the beautiful part of it we'll be
able to move much faster to production
because we already have all of our heavy
code in Python scripts and all we need
to do is build our main uh uh script
reutilize the pre-processing uh modules
uh and import them into our main
function and then deploy this to
production so we don't need to now
scatter around from notebooks copying
pasting code and trying to figure out
what's happening we can just use our
code as we used it in the research phase
awesome so we've reached to the end of
this session um and I want to Circle
back and touch upon every every
principles that we uh talked about I
feel like the most important one is to
host our coding our code in modules and
not in our notebooks so taking our piece
of code once it's ready put it in uh
python script as a module that doesn't
rely on any Global variable and take
everything as input and then we'll be
able to also use this piece of code when
we're deploying to production
have version everything so not only our
notebooks and code but also our data our
models our experiments basically
everything have peer review and to have
peerreview we also need to use some
tools that provide us the ability to
review our notebooks and communicate
over them we'd like to track experiments
with tools like ammo flow weight and
biases clear ml Etc we want to use task
oriented notebooks so break down the
spaghetti notebook that is very very
long for the project and have task
oriented notebooks we want to track the
environment stting and then when
deploying only using scripts for
training and
deployment this is it I want to thank
you all for joining me today uh it was
lovely and also being the opening
session of Pi data Global uh is amazing
I want to thank the pi data Global team
for having me today uh I welcome you to
ping me on Twitter or LinkedIn or also
follow me there or dags up and and I'd
love to learn uh about your use cases so
if you have any questions thoughts ideas
on how we can improve this flow I'd love
to learn also from you so please uh feel
free to ping me uh and connect and I'd
love to chat and by that I think we're
ready to move to the Q&A session um so
I'm going to stop
presenting and I'm going to open the
stage for Q&A
what about data slw workflow managers
like snake maker snake make um test I'm
not really sure what you mean by that um
is it for data versioning or for uh
pipelines can you please elaborate maybe
on the
chat
or open your mic I'm kind of lost here
help um okay so let's move to the next
question um or maybe I'm going to take
it from the chat
myself
regarding perview we use beat bucket for
versioning Jupiter notebooks so what
would you recommend um so if you're
using bid bucket I'm I'm not really sure
if there's if they support notebook
diffing so what you can do is either
take some open source tool that you can
run locally and then use it for diffing
um also the tools that we're using uh so
NB dime uh what we're using at dags up
under the hood um is basically uh can be
used on on your local machine and diff
versions based on either G commit or
giving the path to to different
notebooks um or if you want you can also
connect your bit bucket repo to dsub and
then see the notebooks there once you're
going to connect it you're going to be
able to still use beat bucket and not
leave your G repo from there but also
use all the tricks and hacks that we
have in dsub for data versioning uh
notebook diffing experiment tracking uh
Etc so you can check out NV dime uh
notebook diff and also D if you want to
just connect it plug in place you have
how it works for you and then if you
want to use it locally or with daub
you're more than
welcome it's it's in the free version
just it's in the community tier not
trying to do
anything sketchy here um next question
we're ready we have three more minutes I
am at the verge of
exploration done in seral notebooks and
having nothing modalized yet how do I
get my stakeholders to understand the
work needed for all the tech dep so if I
understand correctly most of the work is
done on experimenting and nothing was
mod modularized so we didn't move all
you didn't move all the code outside of
the notebook um yet so it's very hard
to there is a big technical depth there
and converting from notebook to scripts
when you're going to reach the point
where you're trying to deploy to
production there going to be a lot of
headache uh and also going to be kind of
an headache when you're going to try to
reproduce results now so maybe you can
show it to them now that you're trying
to reproduce your results from I don't
know a week ago um and see if you will
be able to reproduce it it's going to
probably be very hard to do so if you
made a lot of changes to your code and
this can be a very good argument into
moving your code into modules and be
able to diff them easily and see what
changes were done to the code and revert
back very easily uh also run uh tests on
your code which now is pretty much
undoable but if you're going to move it
into modules it's going to be easier or
if you want to you can always like try
to build a deployment pipe plan yourself
like uh use stream read app or whatever
to deploy your uh your model and see how
hard it is is going to be to do that and
this can be also a very good argument to
show what means to move to production
and have everything in notebooks and
what is the technical depth there and
it's going to take a lot of time to do
so so this I see a question from the
audience so moving code to modules
forces a canel restart to reload wait to
reload uh externalized code so there is
a good solution um there is a good
library that enables to do so
um oh I see that codes uh send it I want
to open it while we're going to do it so
basically you you are able to do so
there is a hack for it um I think what
uh codes uh sent here is the auto reload
one uh which enables that without
turning down your or restarting your Kel
but there are solutions for that you are
correct it was true for like four years
ago but now you're able to reload uh
external
code um another question the moment you
have you move a function outside of the
notebooks you lose some of the interact
interactivity because to edit it you
have to reload the oh we just answered
it um so there's a good solution for
that um so for reloading um if you're
hearing us and you can see the chat so
Auto reload is a p is a python package
that you can use so search for auto
reload um in pipie and you will be able
to use
[Music]
it um yeah so I'm getting a ping that we
that we need to wrap it up so I want to
thank everyone for joining us today if
you have any further questions or you
want to uh um ask anything or uh give me
any uh new ideas on how we can improve
this workflow or if you have any your
own solutions that you're using to move
from the research stage to production
I'd love to hear about it let's connect
on LinkedIn or on Twitter um I wish you
all the all the best um and to see you
in the next uh Pi D Global
2024 uh shout out to deab and for
everyone and see you by-bye